لعلها اليوم ام المفارقات على الاقل شيء
من هذا ورد في اخر تقارير خبراء حقوق
الانسان في الامم المتحده يتهم الخبراء
نظام الرئيس عبد الفتاح السيسي بانه يعاقب
المدافعين عن حقوق الانسان ويسجن النشطاء
ويسكت منتقديه بذري مكافحه الارهاب
التقرير يقول ان هذا النمط يشتمل على
ادوات عده منها محاكم الارهاب الاستثنائيه
المستحدثه عام
2013 وكل القوانين ذات الصله ثمه رمزيه
مهمه وفق ما ورد في التقرير بالاشاره الى
ان مصر التي تفعل كل ذلك تشارك في الوقت
ذاته في مراجعه استراتيجيه الامم المتحده
لمكافحه الارهاب مهمه تسمح لمصر ان تحث
الدول الاخرى على اعتماد اعلى معايير
حمايه حقوق الانسان ومن باب اولى ان تلتزم
مصر بذلك وفق ما طالب به التقرير من هؤلاء
الخبراء فيوني اولاين التي كانت قد اصدرت
في ابريل نيسان الماضي تقريرا مشابها الى
حد كبير اعربت فيه عن قلقها من تاكل اضافي
مستمر لحقوق الانسان الاساسيه في مصر عزت
اونلاين هذا التاكل الى ما سمته الاحكام
الفضفاضه الصادره استنادا الى القانون
الشامل لمكافحه الارهاب اهميه مكافحه
الارهاب حفاظا على امن وحياه المواطنين
بين التقريرين لم يتغير شيء سوى زياده
عداد الاعتقالات والاعدامات وتكدس
التقارير فوق رفوف المنظمات الانسانيه
والحقوق المفارقه ان اخر تقارير الامم
المتحده ياتي بعد تنفيذ السلطات المصريه
15 حكم اعدام في يوم واحد وفق ما اعلنته
منصه نحن نسجل الحقوقيه المنظمه وصفت
احكام الاعدام في مصر بالفيض
مشيره الى صدور اكثر من 2000 حكم اعدام
منذ عام
2014 وبذلك تحتل مصر المرتبه السادسه
عالميا في احكام الاعدام وفق منظمه العفو
الدوليه في المقابل مصر لا توفر فرصه او
مناسبه تتعلق بمكافحه الارهاب الا تصدرت
او صدرت واجهه الاحداث فيما يعتبر تناقضا
واضحا لمفهوم مكافحه الارهاب بين ظمات
والحكومات
في مصر لا سما تحت حكم العسكر صوت الناس
اختطفه شعار وتهمته خائن واليوم اخواني
بين من يرفع صوته قديما فوق صوت المعركه
مع اسرائيل واليوم كل من يرفع صوته فوق
صوت ما يسمى معركه مكافحه الارهاب التي
تدعمها نسبيا اسرائيل وفق بعض المتابعين
عن كتب للشان المصري وفي المحصله تلك
الانظمه ظلت تحكم لا هي ربحت معركه ولا
حدت من ارهاب الجوع والفقر والذل
والفساد